actually at VidCon that I got my first
cat hello there I'm Joey Graceffa and
I'm Rosanna pansino and we're hanging
out at BuzzFeed today we are gonna be
answering some questions about our first
of multiple things you go first you go
first you have the jar hey first time
realizing you were famous crazy time I
was a stoplight okay and my windows down
I'm like blasting Selena Gomez and I'll
send one of those scarf tours band pulls
up right next to me and this girl
recognized me all of a sudden the whole
band is like looking over taking photos
and I'm just wanting to enjoy my Selena
Gomez moment I was so embarrassed the
first time I noticed things were
changing I was at a Chipotle oh I was
outside eating a burrito and someone got
very excited and started videotaping me
and came over and said can we get a
picture and I was like sure but I was
like things are changing yeah first
thing you do when you wake up I stumble
to the bathroom haha and I go to the
bathroom does that count
no okay I always check my phone first
who texted me and even check my emails
then you check my social media anything
crazy happened
I mean a know first thing first big
purchase as a youtuber probably at my
house I think yeah yeah I grew up like
not ever really having like a stationary
so the fact that I was able to support
myself by doing what I loved and like
create like a home for myself was just
crazy on my first job job ulation
first job I've had so many oddball jobs
waitress barista dog walker I was a
teacher for a while I'm done at all I
stopped ice cream trucks which sounds
fun sounds really fun right but I had to
go inside a freezer in the middle of
summer like I want to be out enjoying
the Sun
no I had to spend myself inside a
freezer we're killing these questions I
know we got so good overs
first kiss my first kiss was in middle
school it was at my first middle school
yes I mean they will be mad and he was
so cute he was a skater he's be forded
we kiss to a slow song it was a voice it
was a voice to man dance or something
mm-hmm middle school slow dance I was
way too scared to kiss anyone in middle
school I was actually 20 years old when
I had my first cast
no over there in an hi yes who was your
first celebrity crush
in childhood slash TEENhood Oh what
about JT - Jonathan - mom and yes [ __ ]
yeah as a secret closeted gay I agree he
was so cute
first cellphone mine was I think one of
the first cell phones ever invented was
Nokia phone I remember and you can put
different colors on them yeah the case
is at the mall I had the nextel the one
where you push a button you talk yes I
had one of those - that was like my
second cell phone I can't miss that just
oh Anthony from Smosh 5,000% you and him
have gorgeous hair well I like usually
the longest time I would go into a hair
salon with his picture and be like I
want this I had a crush on YouTube and
then I started dating them wow yeah
that's everything alrighty well I hope
you guys enjoyed this little first time
video again I enjoyed your cell phone
and I really have a video I hope you
guys go check out my new show estate the
night season 3 with me in row it's
pretty insane so you should definitely
check it out every Wednesday at 11:00 on
YouTube premium are just got my channel
Thank You BuzzFeed for having us bye-bye
[Music]